nos dicen que miguel mezcla 15
mililitros de blanqueador con 3.70 y 5
litros de agua para preparar una
solución desinfectante para una
guardería las cantidades de blanqueador
y agua siempre deben ser proporcionales
cuando prepare la solución desinfectante
cuáles de las siguientes opciones
podrían ser combinaciones de volúmenes
de blanqueador y agua para la solución
desinfectante de miguel' nos dan cinco
posibles respuestas y nos dicen que
seleccionemos tres los animo a pausar el
vídeo y tratar de resolverlo recuerden
el mezcla 15 mililitros de blanqueador
por cada 3 puntos 75 litros de agua muy
bien trabajemos juntos en esto voy a
hacer una tabla digamos que esto es
blanqueador en mililitros
y esto es agua en litros
nos dicen que miguel mezcla 15
mililitros aquí la unidad es mililitros
15 mililitros de blanqueador por cada
tres puntos 75 litros de agua de modo
que cuál es la constante de
proporcionalidad si dijéramos que el
agua es igual a alguna constante por el
blanqueador cuál sería bueno vamos a ver
por cuánto lo tendría que multiplicar lo
tendría que multiplicar por 3.75 sobre
15 y cuál es el resultado de dividir
3.75 entre 15 dejen de hacer esto aquí
cuántas veces cabe 15 en 3.75 vamos a
ver 15 cabe dos veces en 37 aquí tenemos
nuestro punto decimal 2 por 15 es igual
a 30 restamos nos quedan siete bajamos
el 5 y luego 15 por 5 es igual a 75 y
todo funciona muy bien vemos que para ir
del blanqueador al agua
tuvimos que multiplicar por una
constante de proporcionalidad
a 0.25 así que tenemos que ver cuáles de
estas respuestas tienen exactamente la
misma constante de proporcionalidad para
ir del blanqueador al agua vamos a ver
este tiene 12 y 3 si multiplicamos 12
por 0.25 obtendremos 3 si 3 es un cuarto
de 12 0.25 25 centésimas es lo mismo que
un cuarto así que esta es correcta
qué pasa si queremos ir de 6 a 1.5
estamos multiplicando por 0.25 si 1.5 es
un cuarto de 6 otra forma de pensar en
esto es cuánto es 6 por 25 es igual a
150 así que 6 por 25 centésimas
es lo mismo que 150 centésimas que a la
vez es lo mismo que 1.5 por lo que ésta
funciona
qué pasa con 3 y 0.75 3 y 0.75 lo estoy
multiplicando por 0.25 si si multiplicó
3 por 25 centésimas obtengo 75
centésimas así que esta función
en realidad las tres primeras opciones
son las tres respuestas pero vamos a
verificar que las siguientes dos
opciones no sean correctas vamos a ver
si voy de 20 a 5.5 estoy multiplicando
por 0.25 no 0.25 que es lo mismo que un
cuarto multiplicado por 20 es igual a 5
no 5.5 así que ésta no funciona y luego
para ir de 11 a 3.75 bueno
definitivamente esta no funciona porque
tenemos la misma cantidad de agua pero
la cantidad de blanqueador es menor o
podríamos decir cuánto es un cuarto de
11 bueno eso es menos que 3.75 así que
podemos descartar estas dos opciones
terminamos